hey everyone this is sarah with
registered nurse Orion comm and in this
video we're going to go over how to
prick your finger with a land set so in
other words I'm going to show you how to
use a land set device when poking your
finger tips to get a blood sugar so in
my other videos I showed you how to
check a blood sugar I showed you how to
prime land set and I showed you how to
do a quality control on your glucometer
so be sure to check out those videos now
as a nursing student you're going to
have to know how to poke the finger pads
correctly on your diabetic patient to
check their blood sugar so you decrease
causing them pain you get it in one
stick so you don't have to poke them
again so I'm going to actually show you
how to do that so let's get started okay
the very first thing you want to do is
wash your hands then you want to get
your Lancet device primed and ready to
go now nursing students in the hospital
setting these Lancet devices like BD
needles will typically already be primed
for you so you won't have to prime it
but if you've got your own testing kit
and you will need to prime your own
Lancet so typically how it works and
yours may look a little bit different
but it should work the same way you
twist this part off right here and
you're going to take your land set and
find the grooves on it and you're going
to slide it just inside of the device
like so and then engage the needle I
like to say engage the needle before you
expose the needle because you could poke
yourself which contaminates it so just
hit it inside and I'm just going to show
you how this works see if you hit this
button that engages your needle and you
can just put it back in so that's how
that works
and what you're going to do is twist
this part off and the needles engage and
we're just going to slide our cap in
twist it on and don't hit this button
because you'll hit your needle and
you'll have to reset it
now you're going to pick the setting of
how deep you want the needle to poke
your finger typically one to two is best
for people who have really thin skin
three to four is usually the best
setting that works for most people on
average and then five or higher is for
people who have that really thick
calloused skin for me I'm just going to
do a three so we have our land set ready
and what
going to do is we're going to pick a
fingertip any fingertip you want will
work I like to tell people rotate those
fingertips out because I can get really
sore but I want to use this one and I
really recommend students diabetics
really massage on that finger really get
that blood flow to the tip of the
fingertip because that's going to give
you the best specimen and rub that and
then clean your area with some alcohol
prep get any germs off let it completely
dry and what we're going to do now is
after it's trod we are going to go in at
the side okay you don't really go in the
middle you want to go in the side of
where they're not at the top of the
fingertip really besides the best
because that is shown where the best
capillaries are for getting your
specimen so what we're going to do is
we're just going to go to the side and
I'm going to make contact push it down a
little firmly cuz you don't want to go
superficially and have to poke the
patient again so push firmly and hit
your needle and then squeeze wipe that
first blood drop off because that is
diluted with your alcohol prep and then
just squeeze it and when you get a good
draw take your strip from your
glucometer and follow the settings for
that and it will suck up your blood and
then put galls over and hold and wait
for your result so that is how you poke
your finger using a land set now be sure
to check out my other videos on how to
check your blood sugar how to load a
Lancet and other videos and thank you so
much for watching and please subscribe
to this youtube channel